[Music]
so from what we've just calculated from
the equation of the short shell radius
you'd have to compress the earth right
down to this size the size of a small
marble if you wanted to make it into a
black hole now that's going to be pretty
difficult to do but there's no physical
reason why that could not be achieved
black hole is a region of space where
gravity is so strong
that nothing can escape not even light
and hence it would appear to be black
carl schwartz child in i think it was
1917
uh used einstein's theory of gravity
uh and sold einstein's equations for the
case of a spherical object like a star
and we look at his equations you realize
there's some very special weird radius
which we now know as a schwarzschild
radius
such that if all the matter from an
object were compressed down
to within that radius it would become a
black hole
so for example the sun
if we don't think the sun will become a
black hole it's not massive enough
but if you wanted to make the sun into a
black hole you'd have to crush it down
uh with some gigantic
cosmic crushing device
so that the entire sun was contained
within a radius of three kilometers
the symbol for it is r
subscript s
and it's
quite a simple one uh it's 2
g
m
over
c squared
so g is a gravitational constant you've
already covered from newton
c is the speed of light and m is the
mass of the object that we're talking
about in in kilograms you you're asking
me about the earth and i thought yeah we
can work out how small if you had one of
these gigantic intergalactic crushing
devices that i've never come across but
you know uh if you wanted to crush the
earth down to make a black hole out of
it how small would you have to crush the
earth down to so how small do you think
it would have to be
the mass of the earth i think it's
something like 6 times 10 to the power
24 kilograms
and then divided by c squared c is 3
times 10 to the 8.
so it's around about uh eight
millimeters
so less than a centimeter here's my
messy little ruler so eight millimeters
is about
that big so that line is the radius
that you would have to crush the earth
down to
if you wanted that radius to be if you
wanted to make the earth into
a black hole
uh it's about as you can see about the
size of a marble
there's a
popular misconception in movies and so
on in the recent star trek movie for
example that black holes are somehow
these cosmic vacuum cleaners go around
hoovering planets up
let's say that our sun tomorrow were to
turn into a black hole okay we don't
think it will but let's say you were to
crush it down and make a black hole out
of our sun
uh of course that would be bad for life
on earth there'd be no more heat and
light and we'd all die okay but uh
the earth and all planets were
continuing would continue orbiting
around the sun just as they do now they
wouldn't be sucked in
on if you're sufficiently far away as we
are you just continue on your orbit
one
interesting thing for astronomy is we
now believe that every galaxy
contains a very massive black hole
so
galaxies are collections of stars
our own milky way galaxy contains maybe
100 billion stars over the last 10 years
we've realized that every galaxy we look
at
contains or shows strong evidence for a
very massive black hole
in its nucleus
some of the millions some cases up to
several billion
times the mass of the sun so we're
talking about real monster black holes
what do they look like well the black
hole itself of course is completely
invisible so you might say well how on
earth do we find how do we detect them
and the reason for that is um
there's an intense radiation
radiated very close to the black hole
and that energy all basically comes from
gravity
i'll try and explain that because black
holes are so dense and so compact if you
to throw
stuff onto a black hole by time it falls
down close to the center
uh if it was able to orbit down it would
be traveling at very close to the speed
of light as it all as it falls onto the
black hole it will chain very very high
velocities the particles all bang
together and heat up
and that's how you liberate the energy
from material heating up and colliding
in the immediate vicinity of the black
hole just before it falls in and
disappears forever the evidence for the
existence of black holes has become very
strong now in fact
most astronomers you'd speak to
would say the evidence is now
overwhelming actually the strongest
evidence for the existence of black hole
actually comes from the monster in our
own milky way
if you to look towards the center of our
milky way or milky way galaxy which is
very it's very hard to to see it
actually because you've got to look
through all the intervening gas and
stuff
so you do that in the infrared or in the
radio that can penetrate through all the
intervening material so this is zooming
right in to the dynamic center of our
galaxy so if there is a black hole there
it should be located where that crosses
so this is zooming right into the very
central region and this is an image
taken with a special infrared camera
and in the top left here you can see uh
there's a clock
it starts off in 1992 and we're going to
run a movie over about 15 years
and basically if there is a black hole
there you should see stars moving and
they'll move more rapidly
closer to the central object if there's
no black hole there the stars would
hardly move at all and they'd move
randomly and bear in mind this is real
data
so you see the clock ticking by now
and you can clearly see stars are moving
so we're going to zoom right into the
galactic sensor
and you see this star in particular not
only does it move it undergoes a
complete orbit and we can use the laws
of physics to use all of those orbits of
all those stars to weigh what must be
present at the center of that
centre of our galaxy and what you
require is something that weighs four
million times the mass of the sun it's
essentially invisible
contained within a region not much
bigger than our solar system so for me
that's pretty overwhelming evidence that
there's a black hole in the galactic
centre